sie sorgten für den größten
presseskandal der Republik diese
Tagebücher sind ja jahrzehntelang
weggeschlossen worden in einem Safe
jetzt erst fängt man an sie wirklich zu
lesen
keiner sollte mehr hineinschauen
wir dürften da irgendwie nicht
reingucken wir dürften kein Fotos machen
und wir dürfen nur eine Stunde mit den
Tagebüchern zusammen verbringen bis
heute sind sie dem Stern peinlich wir
haben selber gar kein Interesse daran
dass sie in der breiten Öffentlichkeit
so zugänglich werden und dass die
Inhalte die normalfälschungen sind so im
Umlauf geraten es sind zähe
Verhandlungen bis wir in der Stern
zentrale die gefälschten
hitlertagebücher Filmen dürfen nur von
außen das ist die Bedingung als man noch
dachte sie sein echt war man offener als
heute morgen kurz nach 11 die
Pressekonferenz in Hamburg eröffnet
wurde er liebte das Verlagsgebäude an
der außen als da ein bis dahin noch nie
erlebten Auftrieb von Journalisten und
Fotografen von Fernsehleuten aus ganz
Europa
aller Geheimhaltung zum Trotz gibt es
nun die falschen Hitler-Tagebücher als
Buch der Journalist John Götz fand sie
in Ermittlungsakten und beisammen dr
Göbels hat die öffentliche Verbrennung
von Büchern befördert so etwas Dummes
was hat diese kleine Hexenmeister nur
dabei gedacht er wartet die Meldungen
der Konferenz über die Judenfrage wir
müssen unbedingt einen Platz im Osten
finden wo sich diese Juden selbst
ernähren können
der Stern drehte damals eigens einen
Film über die Tagebücher der im ZDF
gesendet wurde
erst jetzt kann die Summe des
politischen Lebens von Adolf Hitler
gezogen werden die Blätter durch die
Tagebücher also hitler war gegen die
Nürnberger Rassengesetze
Hitler gegen die Bücherverbrennung ach
so er war gegen den also das
irgendjemand also dass die Fälschung
liegt aufgefallen ist
aufgrund der Holocaust
verhandlungslosung das finde ich merke
wie vor dass keine Lösung es waren
Papier und Tinte die den Fälscher konrad
Kujau vor Gericht brachten der Stern
glaubte die mehr vom harmlosen Hitler
normalerweise wenn man was fällt also
mein Fecht korrekt und man fällt
zumindestens unsere nackte historische
Wahrheit da ist ein Hitler der der
dargestellt der gar nichts mit der reale
Händler zu tun hatte und dann frag man
also fragt man sich warum folgten die
Fälschungen einer Agenda über 1000 Werke
cool aus hat dieser Kunst und Antiquität
enhändler gesammelt erkannte den
Kunstfälscher persönlich in rechten
militarierkreisen machte Kuja gute
Geschäfte war Teil eines Netzwerks
haben sich wie gesagt getroffen sich
untereinander gekannt haben
Sachen aus dem Dritten Reich gesammelt
und sie untereinander auch ausgetauscht
sie machen es natürlich alle einig der
der Führer konnte natürlich also mit den
Gräueltaten in den Konzentrationslager
natürlich nicht zu tun haben im Nachlass
cool aus fanden sich hitlerzeichnungen
tagebuchartige Notizen des Führers
Dokumente alle falsch wir haben die
Regierung übernommen
mein Glaube an das deutsche Volk das war
der Massenproduktion hier er hat bei
seinen Kunden immer ein bisschen
nachgefragt was wollen denn die hören
weil er musste eine Idee haben was soll
ich denn jetzt als Adolf Hitler
schreiben und hat er eben das
reingeschrieben was die hören wollten
nach drei Jahren Gefängnis trat Konrad
Kuja immer wieder im Fernsehen auf wurde
von vielen bewundert als der Mann der
den großen Stern reingelegt hatte doch
das so John Götz ist nicht die ganze
Geschichte bei seinen Recherchen fand er
Akten zu einem Neonazi der Kuh auch bei
dessen Fälschungen half es war der
Pressesprecher des berüchtigten Neonazis
Michael Kühnen
die bedeutende Arbeit von dieser kühnen
Fraktion der Nazis war Holocaustleugnung
man sieht das conway-kurier nicht nur
mit der Pressesprecher von Michael
Kühnen zusammengearbeitet hat ok sein
Anwalt war der gleiche Anwalt für
Michael Kühnen der stern-reporter Gerd
Heidemann wusste all das wohl nicht ihm
wurde sein fäbel fürs dritte Reich zum
Verhängnis
Gerd Heidemann selber schade ein Umfeld
aus alten Nazis apologieten um sich das
war im Grunde ein Hitler waren der sich
hier auch breit machte beim Stern im
Stern Film erzählt Heidemann wie er NS
generell auf seinem Schiff traf das
Gehörte zuvor Göring von Himmlers
stabchef ließ sich Heidemann beraten
konnte ihm in vielen Fällen also als so
viel lebenselterer und die Tür aufmachen
die Hitler-Tagebücher so Heike begerte
Marke entsprechen dem Weltbild vieler
alt Nazis jener Zeit eine Holocaust
läuft in diesen Tagebüchern
in sucht dass der Holocaust überhaupt
nicht vorkommt überhaupt nicht
stattfindet es gibt keinen Hinweis auf
Tötungen auf Massen Vernichtung auf
Vernichtungslager all das wird
millionenfach gedruckt die Auswirkungen
spürt sternchefredakteur Gregor Peter
Schmitz bis heute
bereits im letzten Jahr hatte John Götz
zudem Flugblätter veröffentlicht die
sternlegende Henry Nannen als
ns-propagandist geschrieben hatte
sowohl die Rolle von Henry nannten im
Dritten Reich als auch die
Berichterstattung oder Art der
berichteren in den 50er 60er Jahren über
historisch haltet Themen wird
aufgearbeitet als auch die Rolle der
hitlertagebücher im Auftrag von Stern
und Bertelsmann soll das Münchner
Institut für Zeitgeschichte all das nun
erforschen auch personelle Kontinuitäten
zum Dritten Reich es ist höchste Zeit
dass das mal in wissenschaftlicher Form
analysiert wird denn die Unternehmen
haben in den 1980er Jahren damit schon
angefangen in den 1990er Jahren
Versicherungen und dann die
Untersuchungen in der Schweiz und in den
Nullerjahren beginnen dann den
Ministerien
und bei den großen
presse-institutionen hat das bislang
nicht stattgefunden mag Oliver Boga
betreibt ein qiaumuseum hier weiß man
alles ist unecht doch immer wieder so
der Sammler stoße er in Büchern auf
unentdeckte kuhaufälschungen sehr
Historiker haben damals Biografien
geschrieben zu Leuten aus dem Dritten
Reich und gingen dazu zu den Sammlern
von den bekannt war dass sie ihm
authentisches Material haben das aber
sehr oft aus der Feder Kurier stammte es
wäre natürlich jetzt interessant
herauszufinden weil die Bücher
abzuklopfen die damals entstanden sind
wie viel Kuja steckt denn da überhaupt
drin 9,3 Millionen D-Mark zahlte der
Stern für die Hitler Tagebücher nun kann
sie jeder lesen wir haben das abgedruckt
dass wir uns selber besser verstehen wie
war die Bundesrepublik damals 1933 ist
es wichtig die Tagebücher zu
veröffentlichen weil wir nie so nah an
eine Rehabilitierung von Adolf Hitler
gekommen sind
nicht auszudenken wenn Kuja nie
aufgeflogen wäre nun hat auch die
Geheimniskrämerei ein Ende Bertelsmann
hat angekündigt die falschen
Hitler-Tagebücher endlich für die
Forschung frei und ins Bundesarchiv zu
geben